in the last 36 months i've taken 37.9
million dollars in dividends out of my
business all right so that's not
business sales that's not anything else
that's 39 37.9 million dollars in
dividends i've taken out in the last 36
months
and i wanted to lead with that mostly
because i thought it would make the
video a hell of a lot more interesting
for those you don't know me my name's
alex for mostly iowan acquisition.com
and i have absolutely nothing to sell
you today i wanted to talk to you uh
because i had a really interesting
conversation with a um
a couple
that's an entrepreneurial couple
and i caught myself
in this tirade this rant about passive
income and how it's not as cool as
people think it is and i wrote down some
of the notes after the dinner and i
thought i would share it with you
because i think that passive income is
one of these things that people talk
about all the time it's the great a
great headline for uh youtube videos and
clickbait and all this crap and the
thing is is that number one
99.9 of people will never have true
passive income or passive income as you
know in
any material amount if you own stocks
and you get dividends from those stocks
then that is truly passive but
if all you do is actively manage
your passive dividend stocks then you
have active income
and so what i want to do in this video
hopefully
is make active income great again all
right active income's gotten a really
ugly name all right let's be real a lot
of people are like ah you have a job
you know what's real
everyone has a job and everyone trades
the exact same currency for the exact
same output we trade time for money the
only difference is that some of us have
more leverage that we with which we
trade that time for more money but at
the end of the day we are always trading
time for money
period i don't care what anyone says
passive just means you trade a smaller
percentage and so rather than the and if
you've watched my billionaire mental
models video then you'll you'll find
this familiar we like to speak in the
binary of active versus passive when in
reality is
how passive or how active is this income
stream
ah interesting and what i want to do
today is make an interesting argument
for you about why i think passive income
blows all right
so let us begin
number one i live in a building right
now of almost exclusively eight figure
nine figure and ten figure entrepreneurs
so that's ten figures being billionaires
100 millionaires and deca millionaires
and i will tell you this having now seen
especially lots of guys
who are in that category who are 40 50
sometimes 60 years old
observation number one we are not meant
to not work
we are not meant to not work we are
meant to work all right seeing these
dudes
pursue a pleasure filled life or a
pleasure seeking life
is one of the saddest things that you
can possibly imagine it is the weirdest
thing it's like seeing a tiger defanged
right it's like
it's it's
it's not good these guys are gladiators
these are guys who know how to win in
the arena and i'm not trying to project
my desires onto their lives it's their
choice they can do whatever they want
but me as a passive observer of looking
at people that i believe care have a lot
of similar character traits to me i see
a different different paths that i can
go down in my life and i can tell you i
do not like it
so number one
there is no off switch on a tiger
when you turn it off it's not pretty
number two
right now um my wife and i probably make
around
six million ish a year
passively in terms of like we have
virtually like on the let's say if uh
zero is you're literally doing the thing
and ten is uh you forgot that you do
that there's anything to be done uh and
that would be completely passive versus
completely active i'd say that we're
probably like at eight and a half i'll
tell you this
it's not fun when we were actively
involved uh in our businesses
um compared to now
i think honestly it was more fun
um and i think a lot of people always
want to you know portray that their
current state is the most advanced state
um and i can tell you over the last nine
maybe 12 months
man i've done almost nothing i mean the
the three videos a week i make on
youtube are is probably like the most uh
engaging work i do it's like the only
thing i'm like looking forward to uh
every week because of how little that
i'm doing in the business and the reason
i'm bringing this up is this all right
so make sure you hear the right message
from this
i i'm saying this in no way to flex i'm
saying this because i made that the goal
and i think that now that i am here i
regret it
i continued to solve problems in my
business and i had the perspective which
was spoken to me as a younger
entrepreneur which is if you're doing
something if you're actively involved in
the business it means it can't run it
without you which means there is
something wrong
which means you are not as good as an
entrepreneur as you think you are
because you are required to make this
business work which means it's not a
real business right
i think that's horseshit
and i think that i can tell you right
now truthfully because i've walked it
it's not just like a hypothetical idea
like i truly do almost nothing in terms
of what is on my calendar every day and
i can tell you i'm bored out of my mind
and so next next season so starting 2022
i'm gonna be doing some big stuff right
but the entire goal that i optimized
around four years
was passive income it was i want to
build a business that can run without me
and from the dividends that i get from
that business i can do whatever i want
but here's what's crazy that they don't
tell you
if you love the game
then why would you want to get yourself
out of it
huh isn't that weird
it's like i love this thing i'm so good
at it
that i'm going to play basketball so
well that eventually i'm just going to
stop playing and the team's going to win
without me
and so i think what i've given myself
permission to do as of late
is i've given myself permission to work
for the love of working
because i choose to and so i think that
i had this idea when i was trying to
scale my businesses that i wanted
freedom to do whatever i wanted right we
want the freedom to choose
but for some reason over time that got
that got morphed into everything has to
be passive
and i can tell and i'm i'm making this
video so that hopefully you don't make
the same mistake which is like
it's okay to run your business
and it's okay to like it
because i i miss the [ __ ] out of it
i'll be honest with you i do
but in an effort to create space so
other people could rise up and they
could have their own growth and
development i moved away so that they
could have that opportunity and the
thing is is now i can't really jump back
into business because otherwise i would
i would displace people right i'm not
needed
and so it's been an interesting
interesting process for me to walk
through this we have this dream we have
this goal to have this thing that kicks
off cash flow every single month that's
far in excess of what we need to live
but i am in a building where i get to
see the outcome of what that looks like
every day and it's not pretty
and i can tell you over the last nine
months 12 months of what my life has
been it's not pretty
it's not fun
it's boring it's empty there's nothing
to do
and i got this quote from talking more
and i really like it he said
in the bible
the first thing that god did and gave
adam was not eve
it was a job
and i think that there's just been this
this this
i don't know demonic demon of
demonification
i don't know if there's a word there
yeah something bad right people have
been batting
shaking their finger at
work
why
it's what we're supposed to do
and so i think that if we can focus on
and this is what i this is where i'm
kind of walking towards right now is
is now that you at least for me this is
me talking to myself is like now that
you've you've figured out that you can
truly create something that can run
without you you've learned the skills of
not just quote building a passive
business but truly a business that can
run without you and grow comma and grow
all right there's one thing to create a
business that can maintain without you
and still continue to generate cash flow
it's a totally different thing to be
able to put enough talent in place that
a business can grow without you
that is when you actually have a
business i now know that i can do that i
can check that box off
but i feel like now i can be certain in
that i can make the choice to say i know
that i can do that
and i choose not to
because i choose because it is my choice
because i sought out freedom right i
have the option i know that i can build
that but now that i have experience and
i've tasted that fruit
i know that of the different flavors of
fruit the one that i prefer is i prefer
the challenge i prefer the game i prefer
being in the game rather than watch the
team win without me but i just think
that passive income uh is not as cool as
people think it is i think we need to
make active income cool again we're
meant to work we have the freedom to
choose not the freedom to do nothing
because we think that we're we want to
have freedom do all the [ __ ] that we
want to do but the thing is is in the in
the course of building the life that we
have there's nothing that's as that
gives you the rush of business nothing's
as high octane as this right and stuff
that is as high acting as that if done
enough times eventually you're going to
die you got into this game you had these
things in these hobbies that you enjoyed
you get rid of those hobbies to go
double down on the game you go and you
continue to play the game you eventually
win the game right
and then you look back and now you have
all this time because you continue
to trade things to get more time back
get more time back get more time back
and eventually you have all your time
back but you have nothing to [ __ ] do
and so then you're stuck in the position
that i'm in right now which is
what do i enjoy
and i enjoy doing the things that got me
here and so that is what i'm going to be
doing in the next the next chapter of
2022 is i'm going to be doubling down
very aggressively and you'll be seeing
some moves from behind the sidelines
behind the behind the glass of what i'll
be doing but i'll tell you that seeking
pleasure
is not the game it's incredibly boring
um
and uh
and yeah
this is something that no one ever
shared with me and i figured i would
share it with you because moseynation
you guys [ __ ] rock love you guys um
and if you're new to this world uh i
think i said it at the beginning but if
i didn't my name's auction mosey on
acquisition.com we do about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you
and if you enjoyed this video
i'm glad you did
and keep being awesome and i'll see you
guys in the next one